6 14 on a thursday morning now when you
go to a vending machine at your office
grocery store whatever you know what you
see it's cheez-its
it's lays it's a bunch of the same old
stuff
and it's if you're vegan if you eat
plant-based foods only
you can very rarely eat what's there
alex well there is now
john a vending machine it's a vegan
vending machine in downtown las vegas
solving that problem and you know bianca
holman found it she's live at ferguson's
with a look hey bianca what they got
hey alex hey john so you know i have my
card ready to support
they're sold out heat and eat everything
in here the cookie dough the sliders the
tofu bites
sold out but that's a good sign because
again this dynamic duo is celebrating a
year
a year since they've been created this
business so tell us more about
the vintage vegan vending machine i'm
joined by taylor and autumn tell us more
so our vending machine is all frozen and
it has all of our top menu items
including our sliders our cookie dough
and our tofu bites
which is all just like chicken nuggets
and we have four different flavors
buffalo barbecue original and lemon
pepper
and yummy stuff and so tell us you know
i know you all tested this out on some
meat eaters
right what did they say and you always
need the meat eater sale of approval
and taylor's mom is a big meat eater her
favorite
meal is steak and lobster so once she
tried the tofu bites and liked it
i knew that we had something good you
know we're cooking with gas and i know
you all you told me that you kind of
started before you were really up and
running you all went viral
tell me how the reception has been from
folks here in the area so
it's been really amazing i think that
everybody is just ready for vegan food
that's affordable
you know because this pandemic
everybody's looking at the prices and
they're like what are we really spending
our money on and is it worth it
and i feel like this food is worth it
you know well tell me what's next you
got the vending machines i know you do
pop-ups people are probably wondering
when are you going to come to my area
come to centennial hills come to the
east valley come to summerlin
what's going to be next for you all well
right now we're restocking the machine
every week we also restock online so we
have all these same items available for
purchase on our website that are frozen
but the next step is just getting into
our drive-through that's that's the main
goal you know to make it more accessible
and just
have it out there where people can have
good vegan food for a good price
all right well again i i tried it i
opened up the cookie dough
and so i'm taking off my mask to show
you all that if you can have a donut for
breakfast right
if you have a donut i think you can have
cookie dough
and trust me all it needs is a glass of
tall
cold chilled oat milk right yes
that's all you need oat milk or almond
milk we were saying
all the milk is a little more affordable
but uh
this is choice exactly your milk of
choice but all great things and again
restocking tomorrow so if you come down
here to ferguson's
this will be filled with things for you
to try i'm going to send it back to you
guys in the studio
i thought you were going to say a tall
glass of cold champagne yeah
but milk is good with that too well we
were curious what's in the cookie dough
that's what we're wondering is what this
is chocolate chip cookie dough
right chocolate chip they used to make
it bianca is it nut oh what did they use
to make can you give up your secrets to
make like why
is this plant-based cookie dough like
what's in it to vegan butter that's all
i can say
vegan butter but it all tastes the same
yeah so all the items they use are vegan
are plant-based and that's what
again they've used vegan items to create
the cookie dough so from the flour is
there flour in it
yes there is flour there's sugar there's
everything it's the same as any other
regular cookie dough and i think that's
something that people don't see they're
like
what is it if it's not you know milk
butter eggs you know
but it's all the same products yeah but
just plant-based
easy breezy come and try it out john you
can come here
after you get off work and come and get
something tomorrow because it's sold out
right now yeah